you have two kids yes and i've seen you
guys with them and you're
i mean i have i've seen you ashton just
throws them
uh but then you'll go babe i don't know
why my bag hurts and i was like i do
because you're old and chucking babies
like he doesn't
i mean old dish you know what i'm saying
over 40. yeah
uh no i i've seen him on the beach a
couple of times with you guys and you're
just
like real parents and he'll be he'll
pick one of the kids and just throw it
in the air and maybe catch it
maybe 60 of the time he'll go for it
the end is soft yeah so they're they're
six and four is that right
what are they into at those ages so my
son's
into cars obsessed yeah
with cars and we have hundreds of cars
little toy cars um rc cars cars cars
that flip
all cars of all kinds and then my um
my daughter's into space so like
anything to do with outer space the
solar system
um that sounds really good that all
sounds about right yeah
i mean it's yeah i think it's very cute
there was a
at school they like ask you like what do
you want to be when you grow up and my
daughter was like i want to be
um an astronaut chef and i was like
that's
like she likes cooking you know the food
up there is notoriously bad so
it's not why it's gonna change all that
and uh and my son's answer was a
dinosaur
and so i was like well such a species of
life
you have my daughter who's like chef in
space and my son's like not t-rex
it's funny because i would think that
you would you and ashley will be very
good at keeping your kids
grounded because i know when i first met
you when you would come on the show
you would tell these stories first of
all you would achieve this
amazing success of being on that 70s
show and being a star
and being 21 years old but you would get
into fights with your parents and i
remember you once told me
oh yeah i had a big fight with my
parents and so they took they grounded
me so i have to take the bus
to the lot to film that 70s show
yeah and i thought that is a amazing
parenting like
that's absolutely fantastic and b you
were like well you know that's what you
have to do
you you could have probably rented your
own helicopter you didn't do it
i guess i i didn't yes it happened twice
and they took my keys yet twice what did
you do to get grounded you know what to
this day we're
i probably talk back like you know i
come from a very old school family so it
doesn't it it was a very good kid but
you just don't talk back like
um and uh they took my car keys away and
the first time
my parents left me a dollar 25 where my
car keys normally are and they both went
to work and i woke up
ready to go to my car and go to work and
then there was like a dollar 25 and i
was like
so you get on the bus you take it to the
lot you get off in front of the lot and
you go in
to be one of the stars of a tv show yes
and guess who drove me home was it
ashton yeah
yeah sweet it's very sweet we have a
couple of those stories yeah i also
hated chemistry
hated very good at physics calculus math
loved it
hated chemistry and uh to this day he
likes to tell everyone
that he did all my chemistry homework
for me
was that true 100 wow wow
all right now you guys have been during
the pandemic you were homeschooling your
kids kind of you have to
you have to we homeschooled until we
didn't
so i
that would be like two days yeah yeah
yeah
so they can't read
it's fine they're a speech reader um
uh well let me tell you conan i have
skills in life
and uh being a teacher is just not one
of them
and that's okay like that's okay the
second
we finished off that last year and then
in the new school year we started a pod
school and hired
wonderful tutors okay yeah you tagged
out act at a certain point i did because
it was hard to work full-time
and teach the children and parent the
children like
it was it became none of us liked each
other
i didn't like them they didn't like me
it was just it wasn't
right you know i completely know my
my kids are very happy when i go
someplace they like to see me come home
for a brief period of time they like
evidence that i've come home
and then they don't want to see more of
me yeah so if i was around all and
especially if i was trying to teach them
anything it would be insane
yeah yeah my kids like me a little bit
more than that but like
[Applause]